foreign
welcome back to the data science hangout
if you haven't met yet it's great to
meet you I'm Rachel if you want to say
it hi in the chat please do
the data science hangout is an open
space for the whole data science
Community to connect and chat about data
Science Leadership questions you're
facing and what's going on in the world
of data science
the sessions are recorded and they're
shared to the r studio YouTube you'll
notice right now they're a little bit
quicker to go up there than to the
rstudio data science hangout site
but we'll get that going soon as well
too but you can always go back and
re-watch or find helpful resources there
we also have a LinkedIn group for the
hangout too if this also helps you
connect with each other I know right now
people aren't talking as much in there
but would love to have that be a place
where you could continue discussions
after each week as well
together we're we're all dedicated to
making this a welcoming environment for
everybody so we love when when everyone
can participate and we can hear from you
all no matter your level of experience
or area of work so there are three ways
that you can ask questions today
you can jump in by raising your hand on
Zoom
you could put questions in the zoom chat
and feel free to just put a little star
next to it if you want me to read it or
I could also call on you to introduce
yourself
we also have a slido link where you can
ask questions anonymously and I think
Hannah or Tyler will share that in the
chat in just a second
I always frame this as questions but if
you have something to add to a specific
topic or want to share your own
perspective we'd love to hear that too
so feel free to raise your hand for that
as well
um one other quick note just wanted to
mention that if you are currently hiring
we'd love to have you feel free to share
your open roles in the chat as well
thank you all so much for joining us
here today I'm so excited to be joined
by my co-host co-host Patrick Tennant
Patrick I see your title changed
recently in the past month you are now
senior director of data science and
analytics at Meadows mental health
policy Institute so congratulations on
that new role as well the box here
love to have you introduce yourself tell
us a little bit about
Your Role the com the organization and
maybe something you do in your free time
outside of work sure uh thank you Rachel
for for the kind introduction and uh and
for the congratulations uh yeah that is
it is brand new as of this week uh that
just changed so um awesome I wasn't even
gonna mention it but I appreciate you
noticing and bringing it
uh so I am Patrick Tennant um as Rachel
said the senior director of data science
and analytics for The Meadows mental
health policy Institute uh and uh let me
read the mission statement of the
Institute because uh the bosses will
want me to get this one right so uh the
The Meadows mental health policy
Institute provides independent
non-partisan data-driven and trusted
policy and program guidance that creates
Equitable system systemic change so all
Texans can obtain effective efficient
Behavioral Health Care when and where
they need it
uh so that is a mouthful uh but uh we uh
in effect are our uh think tank that
makes policy recommendations um and
helps uh localities Implement policy
changes around their Mental Health Care
System uh we are Texas focused um we for
uh the most of the history of the
Institute have been exclusively Texas
focused uh by the past few years have
become more National in scope and even
International a little bit in that we
are
um we're taking things that we see that
are working here and adding them to
National conversations um so it is we
have expanded some uh those you heard in
the mission statement we are still
pretty Texas focused
um really the organization's only been
around for 10 years or so a little bit
less than that technically
um and uh and so it's not an old group
uh but it's been very uh productive in
in Texas made a lot of changes and and
things um in the mental health system
here are really getting better in large
part uh not exclusively but in large
part due to work of The Meadows
Institute
um the uh 130 or so people that work
there now is the largest it's ever been
we continue to grow and have grown
pretty rapidly in the past few years
um but the data team is only there's six
of us that are full-time and we have a
research assistant as well so we're
pretty small chunk of the organization
uh but we work across the organization
touch a whole lot of different things
um basically anything that has a
quantitative Flair to it they're going
to ask the data team to weigh in on
um so so we work on sort of all levels
of projects
um and uh with all different sort of
subgroups or or teams within the
Institute
um
we on the daily team are primarily
researchers and academics by background
uh my boss the the vice president of
population health is a epidemiologist
um it was it was a tenured professor
before she joined Meadows a couple years
ago and she has built out the data team
uh myself included I joined about a year
and a half ago
um and we've been uh working working
with the data of the institute for
um
for that period of time prior to that it
was a consulting firm that was on a
retainer that did all of the institutes
data work and so we've been
transitioning all of that in-house uh
and building you know structures and
processes around having all of that
in-house uh because it's
a little bit different thing when you
when you own it all yourself versus uh
or getting you know kind of discreet
answers from an external partner
so I'll stop there that was that was a
lot already
um Rachel your last question was about
me personally yeah just curious to get
to know you a little bit what's
something fun you like to do outside of
work sure uh so I have a 15 month old
daughter so uh outside of work time most
of it goes to her uh we're also
expecting a another little one uh in
January so we're we're a little busy
around here
um but uh yes it is it is lots of fun it
is uh honestly not much free time but
but as much joy as I can imagine
um great
well thank you so much we're so excited
to have you here with us today
um it sounds like the data team is is
growing quite a bit and with your new
role I'm curious what is the year ahead
look like or what's something you're
most excited about in the next year
so we are growing uh we don't have a
position posted currently but I could
certainly see one coming coming down the
pipe uh we are uh really really kind of
restructuring how we do all of our work
and we're organizing it a little bit
differently than we have in the past and
that's
um like I said building those structures
and processes has been has been a lot of
the work that we've we've done
um sort of across our specific contracts
or specific uh deliverable level
projects
um and so I'm really excited that we are
going to have a kind of a more robust
set of workflows and organizational
processes uh in which people request
data from us request answers or analyzes
from us
um and then also uh the way in which we
sort of function as a team right like so
like I said we we built from the ground
up a little bit uh we have only recently
started to like really fully utilize uh
git for Version Control so like that's
kind of where we started from we were we
were in Dropbox sharing scripts you know
via email to each other when I when I
first joined and so just building
building from the ground up but I think
those steps are going to make us more
um more effective at the the work we
have been doing but also allow us to
kind of expand and do some more
exploratory and kind of neat
um I don't want to call it Cutting Edge
but like you know closer to The Cutting
Edge kind of work
it's great I see there's a few questions
starting to come in on slido and someone
had a great question it said it's super
interesting to hear about the transition
from using Consultants to an in-house
team I'd love to hear about the
infrastructure build and how you did it
sure uh that is uh that that could
easily take an hour itself uh I will I
will try not to make it that long but
um but when we when we came on when the
data team in-house started proper like I
said when my boss joined a couple years
ago uh there were a few things there
were a few pieces that the external
Consultants kind of owned and uh managed
for The Institute uh one was a big
hospital uh database
um so it's it's all admissions
um and all encounters at er hospitals in
the state of Texas and uh the external
team
um owned and managed this you know and
and sort of like kept all of that on
their side but they would provide answer
to provide you know discreet answers out
of that uh to the to the content teams
and Meadows uh so we took all of that
brought it over put it uh in into AWS
um and built the the kind of the
structure for our analysis of it
in-house totally differently than they
had done it so so we had to like
reinvent the wheel a little bit on that
database and that was a big part of work
the other one was the prevalence
estimation that we do so if you want to
know
how many people in County x uh are
dealing with uh major depression for
example uh we have a proprietary
estimate that we developed
um and that was owned by the consulting
firm we have now brought that over
in-house as well moving all of all of
those the retrospective data and then
the integration of new data as it comes
in each year uh was was a sizable task I
think if there's a
uh a lesson learned that I could take
from that it would it would just be that
we have a good ongoing relationship with
that external consulting firm and that
has been completely critical uh we we
honestly couldn't have done it without
that if we had a
um you know like a cut off or like an
end date with them that was you know
firm and they were going to answer no
more questions to that point uh we would
we would be up a creek and so the fact
that we have been able to go back and
forth with them and they can pull up all
documents that that you know maybe
should have been shared but weren't
originally and that kind of thing uh has
has been totally essential um so I hope
that answers the question that wasn't
too nitty-gritty but but basically if
you can maintain that ongoing
relationship in some way even if it's
just a small retainer in a few hours a
month I think it's probably worthwhile
yeah that's really helpful I see
somebody else asked uh knowing how much
public sentiment affects what issues get
attention do you end up allying with
news organizations to share data and
compelling story ideas
yes uh I don't know that alleyang is the
right word exactly and and to be clear
that's not my my end of the operation
um so I I can't speak to it perfectly
but but yes we're certainly aware that
we need public sentiment to be
um with us on on these important issues
and and so we
have press releases and we work uh we
work on stories and we put out
information in a variety of ways and it
I will say a growing variety of ways
we're really starting to get to that
place where we're going to have
um
nationally focused stories that are that
are coming out where we're sort of
making the case for the the policies
that we believe the the research and the
data support
are you able to give us an example of
one of the projects that your team's
working on
sure uh so at a at The Institute level
one one policy one uh
specifics or mental health intervention
that we really believe in works and that
the research really supports
honestly incredibly strongly it's called
collaborative care uh which in in very
brief is this idea that uh your PCP your
your family doctor or your primary care
physician uh is your main point of
contact for most of your health care and
they track things like your blood
pressure not because they're necessarily
the one who would do open heart surgery
on you but because they're the ones who
keep track of all of this information so
collaborative care is just the idea that
we can bring mental health into that
same sort of treatment space so they'll
track your blood pressure but they'll
also track your you know depression and
anxiety symptoms
and then collaborative care says we
build the system out from there so the
referral Network starts from the PCP
they are getting supported by a
psychiatrist so they you know they know
when is the appropriate time to refer to
a psychiatrist when it's the appropriate
time to refer to a social worker or a
counselor and then they also have
somebody in-house who's helping with
those things and can do some of the sort
of more straightforward uh behavioral
interventions that are possible in like
an outpatient PCP setting
um so that does a very brief and rough
description of the model but but that's
the model and generally we think this is
a good thing it should be supported uh
The Institute as a whole encourages this
through you know we're we're trying to
get and have gotten uh Medicare Medicaid
uptake of it uh as well as private
funders to to pay for these things
because in healthcare that's what you
have to do you have to move the funders
to to move the treatment
um and then all the way down to the data
team specifically which I I think is
probably the point of the question uh
the data team is there to help say
um you know a given County in Texas says
okay you know we we see this we
understand we you want this model to be
implemented in our County clinics right
and in the healthcare that we as a
county provide but we don't know how
many people are going to need each tier
of care under collaborative care right
how many people are just going to be
sort of getting checked on by their PCP
how many will need the counselor how
many will need a psychiatrist and
there's a lot of sort of uh gradation
between those two so then the data team
will come in and work with the data that
that county has uh from their health
care provision over the past X number of
years and and work out estimates using
that that data uh our sort of
foundational prevalence estimates that I
talked about a minute ago County data
from other counties that are comparable
so we'll do some matching on that and
say in other counties that have
implemented this here's how you might
see this go
um and so we're bringing together lots
of data sources and and analyzing them
to with the goal of getting to the
answer of okay here's how you could
plant a staff uh here's here's what you
might need in terms of funding for your
local hospital to be able to implement
this well and how if you're going to
build out this program the kinds of
uptake you can expect over time and
where you should we would you'd think
you'd be in say five years
thank you I'm thinking of like all the
different problems that you're working
on how how does a team prioritize
do you have a process for that yeah no
it's it's uh it's a challenge uh we so
we do we get a variety of requests some
are some are contract level that's kind
of what I was just talking about if
we're in an agreement with uh a
particular healthcare system or uh you
know a state or local government uh some
of them come from legislators right if a
legislator wants to know something uh or
our CEO thinks the legislator wants to
know something uh we're gonna we're
gonna generate that estimate too right
that's going to be an important number
or set of numbers to share uh and so uh
those two things typically bubble to the
top we have to meet our deliverables and
if there's a request that's going to go
to some policy maker somewhere we need
to we need to push on that right that
those things uh even if they have not
been well planned in advance which
sometimes happens uh those things need
to get done it's that they will be
prioritized I think if there is a uh
uh a thing that drops to the bottom that
does not get priority it's our
exploratory work and that's you know
that stinks I'd love to spend more time
doing that we've got a really impressive
team of people and uh and I think we
could really move the needle in terms of
methods and analytic answers uh but we
we unfortunately don't have all the time
that we want to to do those things so
the priority is
um to more directly answer the question
the priority list goes uh policymakers
contracts to everything else
thank you I just wanted to mention
because I know I would say this in the
very beginning and not everybody's on
yet but you can use slido to ask
questions which Hannah just shared in
the chat but you can also raise your
hand here on on Zoom if you want to jump
in and talk to us live or put questions
into the zoom chat too and I can call on
you
but another slido question was how has a
focus on 988 mobile crisis teams or
community-based stabilization for
example impacted your organization and
or your work on the data team
um and for people who aren't familiar
with what that means 988 would you be
able to share that too
sure uh 988 is uh a national number that
is now up and operational that is uh
sort of equivalent to 911 but but
specific for uh mental health needs a
suicidality specifically
um so so if somebody's feeling suicidal
suicidal uh and needs help immediately
they can call 988 instead of 9-1-1 and
and get that help uh so whoever asked
that question is is well informed and
that is absolutely a thing we're
thinking about and and working on uh it
is it is all complicated right uh the
the different communities that we work
with and again we're primarily Texas
focused so the different communities
have different levels of sort of uptake
and buy-in of these things and of mobile
uh mobile crisis Outreach teams or
incots is what we call them
um and and we we believe in the the
methods the the approach the
intervention I think is is strong uh but
you can't force communities to buy into
these things right so it's it's about
providing the information uh providing
the the guidance when there is interest
um in supporting the implementation when
when the time comes uh but in terms of
how we work with that it is about uh
collecting and curating the data to to
show what we think it will continue to
show which is that these are these are
positive programs these programs work
well and support people and uh and
making a clear and compelling empirical
case for that is sort of our task on the
data team so uh how does a
implementation of a mobile crisis
Outreach team and a community impact
that Community uh we're the ones who are
going to be helping to to calculate that
uh it's not I've not worked too closely
on that particular line of questioning
um but but in general we're going to be
the ones we're trying to to quantify uh
the value of these things both in in
terms of
um you know real value like improving
people's lives but also uh Financial
value or return on investment
thank you
Matt return on investment question comes
up quite a bit so I'm just curious like
how do you actually
calculate that thank you it is
complicated yeah we have some economists
laying around who help with these things
I'm a psychologist by background so that
is that is not my area I I actually
trained as a family therapist originally
right so I started a long way away from
the data and have sort of slowly made my
way over uh but uh but our our
economists bring in as many factors as
we can as we can come up with uh to to
try to
um you know
understanding that that there's gonna be
a a ramp up cost right the the building
of the program that is is typically
going to be really expensive and you're
not going to be seeing the uh the return
immediately so so you're going to be at
a loss most likely in the early days uh
but building that over time um in terms
of both population growth as well as
changes and prevalence and need uh once
you factor all these things in and you
take it out five ten X years uh you you
can start to see the actual return on
investment through uh you know reduced
emergency room use because emergency
rooms use is really really offensive
improved uh you know
like taxpayer base like there there are
more people who are able to contribute
to their communities uh if they're not
in prison or in a psychiatric bed uh
there are also more people who are who
are available to kind of like support
that system right so as you as you start
that flywheel it picks up speed and uh
peer support can can jump in and take
people a lot uh take a lot of people
some of the way as is how I should say
that uh so that you really end up kind
of building a self-maintaining system
and the costs go down but the the return
stays there
thank you I love getting to hear when
people come from different backgrounds
and end up in this data and analytics
space so I'm just curious what was your
journey getting here
yes is a funny one uh so I started as a
family therapist like I said practicing
clinically and uh my idea was that I was
going to do that for the rest of my
career when I when I started uh started
graduate school that was the thought uh
I realized pretty quickly that it is
really challenging work I was you know
working in low-income clinics and
working with uh you know child abuse
cases and things like that it's it's
really hard work
um and and my heart goes out to anybody
who does does it full time but I thought
I'd like to have some uh diversity to to
my experience right I don't want to just
be practically I want to do other things
uh so I went to a PhD program in human
development
um I was sort of a like social psych
developmental psych hybrid is how you
could think about it
um and I was uh I was in that program
still practicing clinically but getting
resource training and getting data
training um started sort of learning at
my advisor's knee on on SAS uh doing
data work and I was uh just sort of
enthralled by it so I I taught myself
some SASS and then I learned about R and
I picked it up and I started running
with it because it was it was more fun
than sass to me
um so then my uh my post graduate school
career I I worked in research and
evaluation roles in Academia
um but I was always kind of the most
data focused person on the team and then
you start to you start uh polarized
right you you as the most data focused
person you get the data asks and then
you learn that how to do that particular
thing and you polarize a little further
and then you're you're more data focused
than you were the last time right so as
projects come in you just kind of
polarize to one side or that's that's
what happened to me anyway uh and uh at
this point
um my clinical experience is still
useful like I work for a mental health
policy Institute so that is it's
valuable to have a clinically licensed
person working with the data
um I can speak to what it is like to be
in the room and to sit with someone who
is uh suicidally depressed or with a
family that is really really struggling
and so that is valuable but I don't
practice clinically anymore I just bring
that in uh you know through the data and
through you know how I how I read the
data right then the numbers mean
something a little bit different to me I
think because of experience and so uh
so yeah so so now I I'm really almost
exclusively data focused but I still
have that sort of heart background of
the family therapist yeah that's such a
good point imagine that's incredibly
helpful to understanding the data
I see Caitlyn you put a question to the
zoom chat do you want to jump in
okay but
um I was basically just wondering what
do you kind of Envision for the future
of mental health care and data science
because I always compare this kind of to
bioinformatics that they're criminal
holder system for uh like biology and
data science and like even genomics show
I wonder
um what you kind of envisioned for the
future a mental health if you think
Behavioral Sciences will ever almost
kind of catch up
um to kind of genomics it in more of the
physical life sciences
thank you Caitlin that's an awesome
question I like that a lot and I uh I I
am hopeful that we're on that same
trajectory I don't know about ketchup
um just because you know they've got a
head start right but but I think there
is there is definitely uh growth in that
area for for Behavioral Science uh and
that we can we can certainly move
towards
um more of sort of the the biostats side
of biology right have a have a more
quantitative Focus
um we're pretty large in our in our
Focus here we did generally focus on
populations rather than individuals but
at the individual level I'll say one
thing that I think is is coming and that
will
um will change uh mental health and
Behavioral Science broadly is computer
adaptive testing for uh mental health
concerns so that you know if you've
taken the GRE or I'm sure lots of other
standardized tests to it too but it's uh
as you answer a question the computer
adapts your next question uh based on
whether you got it right or wrong so
it's sort of targeting towards your your
ability right your your level of
knowledge on whatever that test is
um and those they're they're very very
effective at sort of honing in on where
a person actually sits on a level of
knowledge of of that subject that that's
testing on but in mental health uh we
ask lots of survey questions right we
ask people um the phq-9 is the the
standard measure for uh measuring
depression and in most populations uh
and so there are nine questions but
right now they're static right everybody
gets the same nine questions every
single time they respond to that um the
questions don't vary at all all
according to how you answered one or two
or three if you bring computer adaptive
testing into that space you can make one
uh reduce participant burden enormously
so so you have you don't have to ask as
many questions right uh you can use AI
to sort of generate models that will
help to inform based on how somebody
answers question one whether they need
eight more questions or whether they
only really need two more questions
right uh so it reduces percent burden it
makes the uh the output more precise
right so we don't have just sort of a
single number but we have a single
number for all the people who fit into
that really precise category of people
answering those questions in that
particular way or in that pattern of
responses and then it also allows us to
to once you integrate computer adapt to
testing you're kind of inherently
integrating that into
um maybe not your EHR but in into your
data world right into your data system a
lot of psq9s are done on paper right so
so you walk into your uh your counselor
your psychiatrist's office and you might
fill out a form on paper and hand it
back they'll look at it and and use that
information but once you go to computer
adaptive testing you have made the leap
into sort of the digital collection of
that information which allows us to
connect it to everything else right the
ability to connect those responses over
time within that person but also for
that you know whole Community for
everyone being served there and to
understand what is effective for each of
these you know really really precise
subgroups of people
um in terms of how they respond to this
so uh sorry I'm a little passionate
about computer adaptive testing I don't
know if you can tell uh but I just I
think there's a whole lot of potential
there and that's just one one like in of
the the broader world you're kind of
talking about which is which is moving
towards uh you know more advanced
quantitative and scientific uh work on
these things uh Behavioral Science is is
unfortunately behind on those things but
but I do hope we're going in that
direction is that does that help do you
have a specific like thought or question
around that no no I love that answer and
that's really crazy
that's
thank you
this is kind of related so on that on
that topic or you said like behave or
Behavioral Sciences behind on on
in that in general why do you think like
certain industries
can take such a long time to get into
like data and Analytics
that is uh that is interesting uh I I'll
speak to healthcare because it's a good
example of an industry that's that's
lagged on that yeah and it's also the
only one I really I know very well uh so
in in healthcare the the systems are uh
largely not not exclusively but but
largely outdated and kind of archaic uh
and they're they're slow to pick up new
things uh part of the issue in my view
is is the regulation around them right
there's a ton of Regulation uh HIPAA and
high tech and otherwise
um around how these systems have to be
built and maintained
um and and for lots of good reason right
there's it's not that that regulation is
completely unwarranted it's information
that should be protected and handled
carefully uh but there there is uh I
used to work with an attorney who is a
national expert in HIPAA and he'd say
you know it's it ends up most of the
time just being an excuse right it's not
that the law actually forbids this thing
from happening but it is a very very
good excuse to hide behind for for
pushing the boundaries or extending into
into new areas
um and so you know
I think that is probably right that has
been my experience where people will
just say we can't do that because of
because of HIPAA because of high-tech uh
and uh I I wish it was
it was clear that there is flexibility
even within those rules and that those
rules are people are revising them right
there's there's new stuff coming out
there's going to be uh new policies at
least because we're in a different world
now than we were when they were written
and so working uh working towards a
place where we are you know not not
afraid to make changes but but
respecting the data as we need to while
also kind of pushing boundaries and
being willing to uh to take some Chances
with new technologies it seems like
that's a balance we have not all right
destroyed properly yet
it kind of reminds me of like that idea
of
like not being able to submit to the FDA
but how that's changing and then how our
idea around HIPAA is changing I see um
Logan you asked the question in the chat
do you want to jump in
sure hi nice to meet you I'm Logan I was
just curious I don't know much about
like Meadows works with uh rural Health
uh as well because you talk like a lot
about population but I know Texas is
huge so I don't know the dynamic there
and also just your thoughts on how to
better improve like uh data data science
for Rural population health because the
data collection looks a lot different
for those communities
certainly does yeah thank you that's a
great question Logan um and it's good to
meet you too uh I think uh the the
biggest thing that comes to mind for me
is is that the Telehealth transition
right so Telehealth uh as of two and a
half years ago was you know existed but
but was not widely utilized um and now
it is it is not only uh utilized even
even now it's not it's not like gone
away since code but it's it's sort of
instantiated right it's built into
policies people have procedures around
this people have specific rooms for
providing Telehealth treatment
um and so uh and and we have we're we
have good evidence and we're getting
better and better evidence that
Telehealth is effective and that works
in Behavioral Healthcare
um there is still some hesitation and I
again I'm a therapist I do understand
that hesitation of not being in the room
with the person I don't think that's
misplaced but I also don't think the
evidence really shows that uh the
evidence that we have to date says
Telehealth works really well and that
people are able to get good treatment
remotely um so in rural populations that
that solves some of the problem uh yeah
in Texas we certainly have some some
vast rural areas we worked with one
um uh School District level system uh
that was it was serving it was is
providing Services uh for I think it was
14
000 square miles out in West Texas like
just just massive massive areas that
like you know commuting isn't going to
get this done uh they're they're really
sparsely populated and so you need to
bring in Telehealth and I think uh
similarly what I was just saying about
computer adaptive testing uh Telehealth
uh it kind of brings you along right it
Spurs data collection it Spurs the the
digitization of a lot of the information
in a way that maybe hadn't been done
before
um and so I think it creates
opportunities I don't I don't think
we're we're at the end of that I think
we're actually just at the start of that
uh but I but I do think uh rural
population Health has has started two
minutes is about to get a lot more
really high caliber information about uh
treatments and and what's what's needed
and what works um as well well as uh you
know how to set these systems up how to
implement them because it's not a there
are no one-size-fit-all if it's all
solutions out there and so so learning
about how to set this up in different
communities is also really important
information
thank you yeah
see there's a lot of great discussion
happening in the chat as well and Sam I
see you asked the question you put a
star for me to read it um so Sam said
when I worked in public health practice
we wish there were more mental health
public surveillance data sets to use for
our analysis or report development what
are your primary data sources and what
do you wish was available
we have lots of wishes
um we are working right now primarily
with the nisarc
um which I am not if you if you worked
in public health mental health uh you
will recognize that acronym I think but
I I am not remembering it off the top of
my head right now forgive me uh but it's
a large-scale psychedemia psychiatric
epidemiological study of uh people
across the country are representative
sample and and asks
um sort of all of the mental health
questions you can think to ask uh then
they did really in-depth interviewing
and in-person communication with some of
the uh some of the participants
um some I mean like ours sitting and
sitting with these people for hours and
hours and hours and sort of getting
their history as well as
um developing the the methods to track
them over time so that's our primary one
uh in CSR and and ecsa the national
comorbidity replication sample and the
ecological catchment area sample are two
others that we've we've used a lot uh
and then like I said uh we have uh this
really really rich uh data set in Texas
and it's tested specific but I think
other states probably have similar
things that is uh all Hospital emissions
and encounters for the state
um and it's not free and publicly
available but you you can pay to get it
or if you work with a State University
um system you can get it for free and so
that information provides us a really a
treasure Trove of data on
both sort of treatments that are
happening but also we can track people
over time right there there's an
identifier in there that allows us to
connect people across uh encounters and
say something about Trends in in their
treatment and where they're going uh
it's not perfect by any means and one of
the big problems with it is that it's
lagged right now we're still working
with 2020 data which all obviously has
has lots of uh lots of problems and
we're sort of in a different world now
than we were then uh but uh but even
even for some of his limitations it's
really really useful data set
great I I think there's a lot of
suggestions in the chat too and a lot of
follow-up on that question
um Enrique I see you had a follow-up you
want to jump in
sure so I'm just thinking a lot about
the kind of the relationship between
computer adaptive testing and uh how
that relates to you know machine
learning studies recommendation systems
and so given uh the ability to kind of
do that and to create really appropriate
and accurate recommendations and the
question Flows In Like peach q9 or some
other testing you probably need a lot of
data and not just any kind of data but
true outcome data which I think is
pretty
um rare in the mental health care space
so like any recommendations on how to
get that on like minimum viability
things like that
yeah I I I've not really done all of
that myself I have thoughts about it but
I I don't want to speak as if that's uh
you know I've been down that road I
think you're absolutely right
um and if uh if we go towards more sort
of open and less afraid uh EHR usage by
Healthcare Systems I think we have the
opportunity to get that uh so so
connecting you know the social worker
who's talking to that person about their
housing status and and you know their
food stability and things like that
connecting those uh kinds of interviews
with their physical health follow-ups
with their PCP
um as well as their you know changes in
psychiatric medication regimens and
things like that uh that that's all
happening within the hospital system so
it doesn't seem to be impossible that we
that we get towards better outcome data
uh I will say there's a and I I don't
especially want to endorse one
particular company but I know there are
companies out there that are that are
working on that cross-system integration
of data and that's that is their whole
mission and they've gotten some up take
Enrique if you want to reach out I'd be
happy to share the name specifically
with you of the one I'm thinking of uh
but but they have uh as their mission
integrating the you know the social
service and the the city and county
level data uh for that individual with
their Healthcare data with their um sort
of individual self-report on how how
things are going that you might get from
say
a psq9 origin 87 uh that you can tie all
of those things together into a single
system that is accessible to the person
right so that individual has has the
ability to track all of their data from
all these places in one in one system uh
that's accessible to the Health Care
system to the other providers so that if
you know somebody's housing status goes
from stable to unstable uh that their
Health Care system is going to know
about that too it's not just the the
community social worker uh but then that
is also accessible for that kind of uh
long-term outcome review like you're
talking about so if you have all of
those pieces in one place then you can
make pretty pretty comprehensive and
strong claims about outcomes associated
with
um say the the cat version of the phq-9
thank you
I see somebody else asks on slido being
located in Texas does your team do any
research on the impact of language and
or cultural discordance in mental health
treatment
so I have not personally done this uh
yes our team uh language Justice is the
phrase that gets used and so yes that is
that is a big a big Focus for us but
that's more programmatic than research
for us
um again we are uh I think the easiest
way to sort of conceptualize the work we
do is as consultants right we're hired a
lot of times for specific projects or to
answer specific questions
um and so I was in Academia my boss was
an Academia so we have that kind of lens
to us but we don't get to just go out
and explore you know this question
because it sounds interesting to us or
write a grant that would let us let us
do that
um so so no we have not done that
research so I I certainly hear you uh
and I happen to know from from Graduate
School uh there was a professor that I
didn't work with but was in my
department that I knew named Sue young
Kim who did uh did work on on language
brokering and the mental health impact
of that on children which was was
significant and important work so if
you're interested in that uh I would go
look up uh language brokering research
thank you
um I know as you said the team is
internal now but you still act as as
consultants so I'm curious what is that
process look like of it being the
consultant when a request comes in to
you
what is the process or just like how do
you work with like when a different
request comes in how do you treat this
as like a Consulting opportunity
just trying to think like what we all
can learn from that process too sure
sure so uh typically what what we'll
have is is a contract development uh
process with a
um again it's either a locality or or a
Health Care System uh sometimes
foundations but there's there's a scope
of work developed
um well in advance of any uh actual work
happening on our end
um but that lays out okay here here are
the the three or five or seven questions
that we're going to answer for you
um and it's it's not detailed to the
point of the the specifics of the data
set or the analysis but it does provide
here are the things that we're we're
gonna we're gonna tell you we're gonna
give you an answer to this particular
question and the best and most rigorous
way that we can
um and and so once once that comes down
to us and that's uh that is over my head
that is the executive team is sort of
working out these contracts uh but as
those come down and um and and we see
the the scope of work uh we then divvy
up within the team okay who who has time
and who knows about each these
particular areas how are we going to
address this is sort of like efficiently
as we can while also uh rigorously and
this is this is a thing we struggle with
is that like
that tension between rigor and you know
and actually providing enhancer rigor
and actually getting something done
right we uh we very much have the
inclination to to push it everything and
to make it all uh as airtight as we
possibly can but we also have deadlines
and we also have to provide answers
right we can't equivocate uh in the way
that that might be tempting
um even even if the information isn't
perfect I think it's uh it's
necessary for us to provide something
um and this is actually so this this
I've gone a little bit tangent well
Rachel forgive me uh but no that's why I
was asking the question to get to this
I think it reminds me of
um of of Open Source the sort of ethos
uh which is which is that we are
um we're very transparent about all of
the analyzes we do we want we want to be
as open as we possibly can because we
understand that you know one Perfection
is never going to be possible but but
two that we do have to get to some
in-state we do have to make a
recommendation and that might you know
we really Analyze That same data next
year we might get to a different answer
but we need we need some answer for that
policy maker or for that uh client we
need to provide them some information
and so we do the best we can to make it
as strong and rigorous as we can but we
also uh the the kind of the the backbone
of that is that we're transparent about
it we're gonna say all the things that
we know all the ways we did this the
reasons we did those things the way we
did them
um and you know long method sections
make some people's eyes glaze over but
like it feels important to me that that
we provide that and that we're clear
with whoever we're providing that answer
to about the way that we got there and
and do it in a way that is
um reproducible and charitable as in you
know all things that R is trying to do
which is uh part one of the many things
I love about this community
that's amazing I love that
Jordan I think you had a question a bit
earlier that I missed in the chat do you
want to jump in
sure sure
okay okay yeah it's probably less of a
question more um just uh
uh just a bit of a comment too on some
of the computerized adaptive testing
um it's a lot of that a lot of time the
data I look at actually um uh outcome
measures from clinical trials uh so same
things just usually different
um but but there's a bit of a growing
interest I think for a lot of um
specifically within CNS Psychiatry and
the other sort of mental health fields
that there's more interest in developing
some of these I guess what we call
Patient reported outcomes then some of
these clinical reported outcomes where
the scoring process isn't necessarily
burdened by a individual in their own
clinical experience but is
um a bit more standardized across thing
across um patients and patient
populations so just you know uh like
increased um I guess kind of some
increased research and understanding of
stuff like computerized system testing
is is really beneficial for making sure
that when we're looking at these data
sets that contain these sort of outcome
measures that they aren't um so
influenced across uh you know they
aren't completely or they're less
influenced and less biased from sort of
who's completed that assessment and that
your in your data are a bit more um have
a bit more uh Integrity between
themselves because it's great to get a
large data set but then
um so hopefully all the data is all um
still very valid and very um uh
communical between itself as well which
I think um so I you know I I guess if I
want to turn that into a question
um how um a lot of their uh that you're
looking at with some of the outcomes
measures um
do they come from a good like sort of
variety of sources and is there anything
um they have to do to sort of aggregate
some of the uh sources together like if
this one assessment is used in this one
place is there a way of uh rationally
converting it or using it as
um similar to another assessment that
might still be a measure of
um depression or depressive symptoms but
isn't actually the same measure uh
because I know that's a that's a problem
I run into a lot
yeah Jordan thank you that that is an
awesome question and uh it sounds like
we should be friends uh I I think
generally what we're trying to do is is
to triangulate right to bring it all
together so as you were as you were
talking about in the the problems with
uh a clinician reported scale uh you
know there are there are not the same
but sort of parallel problems with a
patient reported outcome scale right
like you you get uh you get that sort of
inherent bias and so so really what we
prefer I think would be to have both of
those things uh available to us at any
you know any given moment or for any any
particular analysis so we think of that
as as triangulating and bringing
together the data sources for uh for a
particular question um getting as many
sources of information as we can uh but
the other piece is uh is that when we
have say a static estimate of of uh
depression in some some population uh
generating appropriate confidence
intervals for that and how to
extrapolate that to a new population is
something we're thinking about right now
and what's the most kind of uh you know
scientifically appropriated or
statistically appropriate way to do that
um and we're we're playing with some
some bootstrapping methods that I think
are going to really help us do that
better and I I can't explain it super
well myself at the moment but but I
think this is a technique we're going to
start to utilize uh for small
populations right because you can't you
can't calculate a standard error in the
same way if your your sample is too
small and so we we work with some small
and pretty specific uh communities and
sub populations and so so to be able to
get to a an appropriate estimate for
populations like that in other places uh
I I think we're going to explore the the
bootstrap option
yeah yeah that would be that's that
sounds really interesting and then I'd
probably hopefully that the measures are
also sort of a bit more uniform the
dimensionalities and and traits that
they're measuring that
um
a lot of times a lot of the outcome
measures just support us maybe just like
a total score some index or normative
value but really you're you're measuring
four domains here and then three domains
here so you're you're not really making
too equal they're not that equal they
probably correlate they probably look
about the same but they're still
measuring some different traits within
them
yeah exactly uh the the sort of again
there's there's that tension between
like being as as psychometrically
rigorous as you can and uh actually
getting things done right because if we
if we uh we spend all all day talking
about the the you know item response
theory for a particular set of questions
uh the the policy makers will stop
coming to us to answer their questions
right and so so it's not I I can nerd
about nerd out about that stuff all day
long and we have to remind ourselves the
times that we have to get to a
particular answer so that is that
balance certainly yeah they're they're
mostly the same as usually what I
they're not the same but they are
thank you very good thank you
I see um Coulter was was resonating with
what you said about like archaic and
outdated systems in government sector
Public Health as well
so just wondering if people are feeling
that in their own organizations what's
like the best
first step towards getting out of some
of these like archaic and outdated
systems
I think uh I I was thinking about this
particular question but at a broader
scale of like how do how do we get
Society out of archaic and outdated
systems and and how do we move people
forward and actually this is this is
going to sound super cheesy but I I
really I mean it Rachel I think it's I
think it's this like I think it's what
you're doing here I think is the the
inclusivity and the the welcomingness of
this uh that is that is the answer to
that and so to to bring that down to you
know a sub Society level uh I think in
your organization uh to to have the the
people who are running those archaic and
outdated systems uh welcomed into the
conversation
um and and not you know not brought in
as in we're gonna knock your system out
and do something way better and we're
gonna you know sort of send you away but
to welcome them along with the people
who want to make the change along with
people who don't understand the
conversation at all uh to get everybody
there and feeling like they can
contribute and have enough understanding
to to really be a part of that is is a
way way more efficient and effective way
to make change in my view than than just
trying to convince a single you know top
level leader or trying to convince the
the gatekeeper on the archaic system
that it needs to change uh I I think you
want you want everyone everyone there
everyone a part of it uh or else they're
going to be a lot of a lot of barriers
and a lot of roadblocks uh that uh I
would think will hinder progress
um so you know I don't have that power
if we work with the Healthcare System I
don't have that power to congregate all
of them and to change their system and
that's not our ask right that's not the
thing that we're there to do but I I do
think there is a uh a way in which
internally to that system that just
creating a culture of inclusion and
welcomingness around around data and
around Tech Systems uh is is a way more
effective uh a way more effective path
forward
that is amazing I love that
I want to go share that everywhere right
now
yeah
you're saving the world didn't you
no they thank you that that's such a
great Point too like
bringing people into that conversation
and making sure that that they feel
welcome to it as well
let's see I am gonna go jump over to
slido and see oh Catherine you had asked
the question a bit earlier about some of
the exploratory work do you want to jump
in
sure
um this is a much less weighty question
than some of the previous ones is not my
area at all but uh you had mentioned
earlier about
um maybe wanting some time to do some
more exploratory work and I'm just
curious if you're going to elaborate
elaborate like if your team was not uh
weighed down with all the other
priorities what would you focus on
thank you Kevin I love that question uh
it's like like I said we don't get to
focus on as much as I want so I'm happy
to talk about it here uh we
um we have a few irons in the fire I
guess you could call them around that uh
one is is predictive modeling at the
population or ecological level um so so
where are needs going to be can can we
see into the future a little bit uh
about about what uh the community's
needs will be
um would be enormously valuable so so in
terms of uh planning for services
um Building Systems and structures uh
it's not ever going to be precise down
to an individual person or for an
individual person over time we're not
going to get there and we understand
that but if we could get some foresight
into what community X will will need
next year or the next three years uh
that that could be incredibly valuable
information
um and we we are not a team of machine
learning experts uh but we're pushing at
that and trying to trying to train
ourselves up on that so that we can
hopefully provide some information with
some foresight so that's that's a big
one the other one I'll say is uh this is
sort of related to the bootstrapping
thing but we have we have other related
projects around around simulation and
sort of like uh Monte Carlo models using
using distributions to try to better uh
better quantify the risk associated with
certain things
um we are a uh
often tasked with providing a single
number and we are inclined to provide
ranges uh but to make those ranges as uh
as strong and as sort of like uh well
grounded as we can as a task that we
we're working on and so if we can do use
some simulation models
um or plug in you know uh reasonable
distributions uh to to generate ranges
for our estimates I think we're in a
much better place uh there's like
there's some really kind of basic
probability theory behind all of that
but there's also some some fairly
advanced stuff that we're that we're
trying to do in that same vein
um and that's these are the things where
it's like we don't we don't have the
time to teach ourselves to have the time
to do the work and and we wish we did
because we think there's there's a lot
of really the high value opportunities
there uh but uh it is what it is you get
paid what you get paid to do yeah yeah
thank you I know media and and
legislature sure love those single
numbers don't they
thank you thank you Kevin
thank you everybody for all the
questions too I I did just want to
um mention again that
if you are hiring for any open roles now
that you'd want to share in the chat we
do have a a few community members who
team whose teams have unfortunately
recently had to lay off a few people and
we just wanted to be able to pull
together any open roles that we know
about and I would be happy to like
collect those and put it into the
hanging out community on LinkedIn but
also with the recordings as well so I
just wanted to call attention to that
again
sorry I think LinkedIn is dinging in my
ear there you go
um
just to check were there any questions
that I may have missed earlier from the
zoom chat or on slido feel free to raise
your hand on Zoom here
yep
yeah you go ahead I was just gonna say
while we were waiting for a question to
pop in uh I I would be totally happy to
connect on LinkedIn
um and and to do anything I can to help
any of y'all please feel free to reach
out I'm really have uh had a lot of
people be generous with with their time
with me uh in in the past and and still
through today so so please feel free to
connect and I'm very very happy to to do
what I can to help
thank you very much I'll share your your
LinkedIn and the the chat too I see
Brady you just asked the question into
the chat you want to jump in
or I can start by
asking the question what are some
analysis problems that are particularly
pronounced in the mental health domain
or maybe what are some thorny inference
areas you would warn others about before
waiting in
so it is enormously important in in
mental health to uh to keep in in mind
always that that we're talking about a
sensitive topic for the people who are
providing the data right and so this is
I don't think exactly what you're asking
about Brady but I just want to say it
again uh that having that sort of the
the heart behind the analysis uh is is
very important for us and something that
we focus on a lot we don't want to uh
we don't want to purely quantify these
things we want to remember that there's
there's qualitative information in these
people's uh in these people's lives too
and so it's it's necessary to to always
keep that in mind in terms of the actual
inference uh we are we're interested in
change over time A lot of times but uh
as Jordan was alluding to earlier uh
some of our measures of of these things
for for the Baseline and for the
follow-up are are not especially stable
uh so inference are about unstable about
changes and inherently unstable measures
is uh is complicated
um at best and and I think uh you can
actually end up with a lot of
overconfidence about the the change or
the the impact of something uh if you
you know if if you're Reliant as we
often are on on unstable measures so
that that's the thing I would say is
that uh maybe computer computerized
adaptive testing can help uh but but we
have kind of inherently flawed measures
of a lot of the outcomes that we're
interested in um and so ascribing you
know impact or change of a treatment or
a program uh is uh is tricky and uh be
aware of the quality and the validity of
the measure you're using is what I'd say
thank you
I have one selfish question
um or maybe not selfish but a lot of
times
um I'll hear from people who are trying
to build communities within their own
organizations
and just going on what you're you're
talking about how important it is to
welcome people into these communities
I'm always interested in learning what
other teams are doing or what challenges
they're facing in this area
um and just curious what this looks like
from your team's perspective do you have
this internal data community
yes we do uh we could certainly do it
better and that's that's a priority of
mine is to always be improving around
that but we have our core data team we
also have people who are working with
data who are embedded within the the
content team to the subject matter
expert teams um and so there's uh
there's sort of uh you know a core group
but then also some tentacles that
doesn't sound very nice but I'm thinking
of an octopus uh out out through the
organization uh of other of other data
uh related folks uh but really the the
the main goal for us is to just have
people feel confident right when we work
with the subject matter expert teams we
want them to have confidence in that
conversation to push back on us if we
say something that doesn't make sense or
to uh to understand that they have
expertise that is absolutely essential
to this and that that really weird it
seems like they're coming to us and
they're dependent on us but but actually
that is the inverse like we can't do
anything useful without the subject
matter expertise teams um and so so
building confidence is is actually my
like number for one priority and
welcoming an inclusion inclusion is is a
part of that but also getting people to
see uh real world examples of that of of
where these numbers might say this but
but because you know about X Y and Z you
can tell us what this actually means you
can tell us how this is important or how
it's not important even though you know
statistically we could make an argument
that it is
that's extremely helpful thank you so
much
thank you for sharing all of your your
insights and experience with us it's
been a pleasure I know we just hit the
top of the hour here thank you for
joining us and thank you all for the
great questions as well
yeah thank you guys very much it's uh it
has been fun and like I said I'm really
happy to chat and um Rachel again this
is uh it's an awesome community so thank
you for doing this thank you we
appreciate it and we um you put
Patrick's LinkedIn into the chat here
but I'll I'll be sure to share that
recording and the The Hangout group on
LinkedIn too thanks all